at the beginning of success an ultra
adventure miniseries in 30 minutes and
eight episodes episode 1 my call
to adventure
before I start I want to make it clear
that I don't know much compared to what I
should know all success in my life had
more to do with what I knew  how to deal with my
ignorance rather than
whatever I tell others to do sounds presumptuous to me
but I will do it because I believe
that the principles that made me
successful can help others achieve
their own goals
I am at a stage in my life where  it
is more important for me to pass on what i have
learned about being successful than to
be more successful for me
what you choose to do with these principles
is up to you you must think
independently as only you can
develop your own principles
based on your own values ​​this
leads me  to my first principle the most
fundamental you have to think for
yourself about what is true
which said let's start at an early stage i
discovered that  I need principles
principles are smart ways to
handle things that are repeated in
similar situations there are principles
for everything from skiing to
parenting to cooking and so on I will
share with you some of my most
important life principles that
affect how we approach everything
we do
not  I started with principles I acquired
them throughout a lifetime of experiences
mostly by making mistakes and
reflecting on them My
life principles are simple but they are not
complete I keep fighting to make the
best decisions
I keep making mistakes and I
constantly learn new principles This is
the reality
at  beginning I should escape the
conventions around me which
meant I should think for
myself unless you want to have a life
directed by others you should decide for
yourself what to do and you need the courage
to do it
but I didn't know that when I started I
just learned it  going out on my adventure in
retrospec  tive I see now that English is
like a river that leads us to encounter
realities that require us to make
decisions
we cannot stop this movement
downstream and we cannot avoid encounters
we can only focus them in the best
possible way
during your life you will have to face
millions of  decisions the quality of your
decisions will determine the quality of your
life in the course of my life the
most valuable things I learned were the
results of mistakes that I
reflected on to help me form my
principles and thus not repeat
mistakes these principles
led me from being a  very ordinary
middle class boy on long island to achieve
great success in conventional terms
work and relationships have also brought me
significant meanings that
I value even more than those conventional successes
I am often asked how I did it I can
assure you it was not because of me
uniqueness was the result of a
peculiar approach to life that I think almost
every  anyone can adopt start by
admitting reality and facing it in the
second episode i will explain what
this means the path you will take in life is
your most important decision in my case i
wanted my life to be wonderful and i
feared boredom and mediocrity
more than failure  Since I didn't start
with money and I didn't need more than bed
and food,
I was able to guide my decisions in order to
run my adventures.
Since I was a child I ran after the things I
wanted, I caught
myself, I got up and I ran again until
I crashed again and every time I
fell  I learned something better and it makes me
shudder sometimes repeating this over and over again
I learned to love this process until the
falls so I met reality and
learned to face it which inspired
another of my fundamental principles the
truth is the essential foundation to
produce good results
by truth i simply mean
how the world works i think nature
has given us the laws of reality l  We
humans do not create them but we can
use them to promote our own
evolution and achieve our goals.
Understanding this made me hyper realistic, that
is, someone who has discovered the
great rewards of
deeply understanding reality, accepting it and
working with it as it is and not as
I would like it to be.  outside
when I say that I am hyper realistic
people usually think that I say that
dreams are unrealizable that is not
true without chasing dreams life is
banal what I mean is that for
me hyperrealism is the best way to
choose our dreams and then make them come true
having big dreams and facing
reality coupled with having great
determination will result in a successful life i
think this formula is valid
for everyone
but what a successful life looks like each one
must decide for himself what
success is i don't care if he wants to  being a master
of the universe or living under a palm tree or
anything else I really don't
care everyone chooses low goals  based on
your values ​​and decide how to achieve them
but we all need effective approaches
to decision making especially
when dealing with problems mistakes and
weaknesses that block our path
to success we must accept all
our realities especially the
hard ones that we don't want to be
true in the beginning see  these harsh
realities caused me a lot of pain but
I learned that it was just a psychic pain
and that by looking at things
differently that was where the difference lay
I began to see problems as
puzzles that cns would reward me and if
I solved them they would help me face the
problem in question  and they would give me
principles for handling
similar problems in the future
I learned to treat pain as a sign
of a great learning opportunity
at hand and this led me to
realize that pain plus reflection equals
progress meditation has been invaluable in
helping me  to see things like this
I saw that when I calmed down he accepted my
reality and I faced it the rewards
gave me pleasure and the pain vanished
each one has the unique ability to
think logically and reflect on
himself and his circumstances in order to
direct his own personal evolution to
do well that pain to follow a simple
process of  five steps in episode 3
explore how to use it we have discussed
how important it is to reflect
carefully after experiencing the
pain when i did it i used to be able to
discover principles that would prevent me from
repeating the same mistakes in the future
and i came to see that being successful was
just five steps  the first
step is to know your goals and pursue
the ones that are best for you and it depends on your
nature so you must really
understand yourself and know what
you want to achieve in life the second
step is to meet the problems
that stand in the way of your goals
goals
these problems are generally
painful if mishandled there are those that
can lead to death  ruin but to
develop you must identify these
problems and not tolerate them the third
step is to diagnose these problems
to get to their roots
don't rush to a solution take a
step back and reflect to
really differentiate between the symptoms and the
disease
the fourth step is to design  a plan to
eliminate the problems here will determine
what you need to overcome them
and the fifth step is to execute those
plans by encouraging you to do what is necessary
to move towards your goal a
successful life consists essentially of
repeating these five steps over and over again
this is your evolution  personal and this
process you see everywhere it is a
law of nature think of any
product any organization or
any person you meet and you will
see this is true for them
evolution is simply a process of
adapting
conceptually it looks like the process of
five  steps I outlined as you
work your way through this process often
painful to naturally ascend to
higher and higher levels of success
I found that as the
fight improved it did not get easier
because the more capable I became the greater
the challenges to take on
as each one has their strengths and
weaknesses for different things
most  you can't do the five
steps well not facing this reality
means that you could stretch issues from
what you should and the higher heights the greater
your falls can be
to all of us sometimes terrible things happen
in life they can ruin us
or improve us profoundly depending on how we
handle them something like that  it happened to me in
1982 in episode 4 i'll show you what
happened and what i did about it
we move forward until we hit
setbacks whether we overcome them and
move forward or go backwards
depends on whether or not we want to face
failure objectively and make the
right decisions  for the loop
to point up again
something terrible happened to me in 1982 when i
bet everything  how much I had to a depression
that never happened
the period 1979 1982 was very turbulent
for the world economy the markets and
for me and I believed that the
US economy and with the world economy
each one was heading towards a
catastrophe this opinion was very
controversial I wanted the  big setback and i
took a big risk very
publicly and i was terribly wrong
after a delay the stock market
started a big rally that lasted 18 years and
the us economy enjoyed the
fastest growing period in its
history it was like getting hit on the
head  with a baseball bat i
had to cut my losses
so bridgewater my company got an
employee i
was so broke myself i had
to borrow four thousand dollars from my
father to pay off my debts but the worst part
was having to fire my  People I held
dear were
hesitating whether to give up my dream of being a
freelancer or play it
safe and work for others in a
position that  e required me to wear a tie
and travel every day even though I knew that
for me taking fewer risks would
mean a lesser life
such a mistake and especially so in
public was painfully humiliating
it still shocks and shames me how
arrogant I was by
totally trusting a perspective  Totally
wrong,
although making you many more times
than I was wrong I allowed one bad
bet to nullify all the good ones
I made
I thought a lot about the relationship between
risk and reward and how to manage them
but I couldn't see how to get the
rewards I wanted without risk
unacceptable this happens to everyone it
will happen to you you will
lose something or someone without whom
you think you cannot live or you will suffer
a terrible illness or injury or
your career will fall apart in your eyes
you will think your life is ruined and there is
no way forward
but they will pass
I assure you that there is always a
better way to get ahead than
probably  e you still don't see
you must think hard to find it
you must accept your reality in
episode 5 i show how understanding this
led me to think about how
reality works and how
best to deal with it sometimes things happen that are
hard to understand life
often seems so  difficult and complicated
too much to cover at once my
deep pain made me think
deeply about my position it also
made me think about nature
because it guides us to what is
real so I thought a lot about how
things work and that helped me
take  perspective regarding myself and
my situation
and may they live all the laws and
forces of the universe were created and
pushed forward interacting with
each other like a
perpetual motion machine in which all the parts and
pieces form machines that work for
a time  they disarm and re-form
new brands this continues until
eternity
and that everything is a machine the  structure
and evolution of galaxies the
formation of our own
solar system the formation
of the earth's geography and ecosystems our
economies and markets and each of
us individually are machines
made up of different machines
our circulatory system our
nervous system that produces our
thoughts our dreams our
emotions and all other aspects of
our characters
all these pages evolved together
in time to produce the
realities we encounter every
day and I realized that I was just a
tiny part in a nanosecond
deciding what I should do
even though this  This perspective may sound very
philosophical. It was very practical for
me because it showed me how to better face my
own realities.
For example, I observed that
most things repeat themselves in slightly different ways,
some in short and obvious cycles that are
easy to recognize, and that way
we know how to face as  the  24-
hour day others so infrequent that they have not
happened in our lives and we go into
shock when it happens like a
once-in-a-century storm
and some that we know exist but
that we face for the first time like
the birth of our first child the
Most people make the mistake of
treating these situations as if they were
unique and face them without the right perspective
or principles to
help them overcome them, I
understood that if instead of facing
these events as unique, I managed to see them
as just one more of those and face it
like a biologist to an animal by
first identifying its species and
then applying principles to
manage it properly by being able to see that
these events unfold
similarly over and over again I could
more clearly distinguish
the cause and effect relationships required by their
behaviors which allowed me to
develop principles  best I could
express both in words and
algorithms I learned that  Although almost everyone
expects the future to be a
somewhat different version of the present, it is generally
very different. It is because
people's judgment is formed by recent events
and does not take into account those that have not occurred for a long time,
perhaps never in their lives,
but  repeat
with that perspective I realized that what
I missed when he
wrongly predicted a great depression was
hidden in the patterns of history and
that my newfound understanding of
these patterns could help me make
better decisions in the future and as I thought about my
challenge to balance risks and  rewards i
understood that these two naturally go
together i came to
see that to get more out
of life you have to take more risks and that
knowing how to properly balance
risks and rewards is essential to
living your best life
imagine that you have a choice between living
a safe life and a boring one  staying
where you are or a fabulous life if
you risk
successfully traversing a jungle  dangerous
in essence that's the choice we all
face for me the choice was
clear but that doesn't mean the
road ahead was lacking in challenges I
still had to face two
big barriers like everyone else in episode 6 I would
share some
invaluable techniques I learned to do it
the right way  best way i can't tell you which
is the best path in life for you
because i don't know how important it is for you to
achieve great goals compared
to how much you care about avoiding the pains
necessary for it
this is the courage i spoke about before and
each  you need to explore these things for
yourself after my big mistake
predicting a depression i was at one
of those crossroads in life like we
all are if i had just picked a
normal job and played it safe i would have
come to a very different life from the
one i  I have had
but as long as I could pay for house and
food and educate my children the only
option for me was the risk of
crossing the jungle in pursuit of  best
possible life
my big mistake betting on a depression
led me to a healthy fear of being wrong, that
is, it gave me a deep humility that
was exactly what I needed
at the same time it did not prevent me from
aggressively going after the things I wanted
for success I needed to see  more than
I could see for myself
but it was blocking me the two
biggest stumbling blocks everyone
faces ego and blind spots
these barriers exist because that's
how our brains work let's explore
the ego barrier first by referring
to your ego barrier  I'm talking about
the parts of your brain that prevent you from
admitting your weaknesses objectively
so you can understand how to
deal with them.
Your deepest needs and fears
are in the areas of your brain that
control your emotions, and your
higher level conscious thinking doesn't have
access to them.  them
and how our need to be right
can take precedence over the need to know
the truth
is that we  we like to believe our
opinions without subjecting them to a
particular stress test we don't like to
see our mistakes and weaknesses
we instinctively tend to react to
their exploration as if it were an attack
we get angry even when it would be more logical to
open up to others' comments
this leads us to  decide worse to learn
less and not reach our potential
the second barrier is that of blind spots
we all have blind spots the
barrier of blind spots consists of
thinking that we see everything
but the simple fact is that nobody can
see the complete reality naturally
nobody  can understand what they do not
see just as we have different
auditory vocal ranges and color perception
we have different ranges to see and
understand things for example some
see the whole picture better and
others stand out edges details
some think linearly others
are  more lateral while some
are creative but not reliable  others
are trustworthy but creative etc.
by digesting how our
brains work each one perceives the
world around us differently
by doing what comes naturally to us
we do not take into account our
weaknesses and we crash or
we continue doing that or we change
aristotle defined tragedy  as the
terrible result of a fatal flaw
that if corrected would have led to a
wonderful result
in my opinion these two barriers are the
main impediments to making
good decisions nor fear of being wrong
it gave me the open-mindedness that I
needed and that changed everything  taking
risks and going bankrupt from time to time
was not acceptable neither was taking no
risks and not achieving exceptional results i
needed an approach that
would give me exceptional positive results
without also giving me the
negative exceptions when i discovered it it
turned out to be my holy grail
to achieve it i had to replace the
joy to prove my reason why
joy of knowing the truth
this need prompted me to seek out the
wisest people I could yesterday who would
disagree with me I was not interested in
their conclusions I just wanted to see
things through their eyes and have them
see things through mine
so that we could discuss things
together and find out the truth
put another way what I wanted most
from them was thoughtful disagreement
going from seeing things only through
my eyes to seeing them through the eyes of these
wise people was like going from seeing
black and white to read
a 26 issue in color
then I understood that the best way
to get through the jungle of life is
with insightful people who don't
see things the way I think in the
five-step process I described earlier as
I said we work so  different mind that
not everyone can do the five steps well
but you don't have to do them all only
others can help you who do well
what you don't that
work perceivably  see things that you
can't you just have to let go of
your ego's attachment to being right and use your
fear of being wrong to open your mind to
these other opinions
so you can point out the risks and
opportunities that you would miss on your own I
saw that taking this approach  of
radical open-mindedness and
credibility weighing the opinions of
others significantly increased my
probability of making the best
possible decisions this allowed me to
scale greater heights and challenges
before I would have always wanted to do
what seemed best to me but now I was
looking for the thinkers  as staunchly
independent as I could find
I continue to do nothing better than to share
a mission with extraordinary individuals who are
radically honest and
radically transparent with each
other
this approach led me to create a
company with a unique meritocracy of ideas
that operates in a unique way that
spawned  also unique events
in a meritocracy of ob  we will have
the best of all, each one thinks
independently and then we work out
our discrepancies to arrive at the
best, however, not all opinions
have equal value and we had to
learn to distinguish between bad
and good ideas to reach
the best decisions, in other words  In this way
we needed to weight
individuals' thinking for credibility, but
that is another matter that I will explain in
my working principles. At this very
moment, there are numerous wonderful
opportunities as well as
dangerous risks that surround you and that
you would not perceive if you saw them without the
distortions of  your ego and your blind spots
you could deal with more effectively if
you can acquire this ability and with
practice you will improve your life
radically in episode 8 concludes
our journey together so you
can start your own journey so
far I have described how I learned to
deal with my own  realities my
problems mistakes and weaknesses  and how
I surrounded myself with others who could do
things better than me
this was the most effective way I
discovered to make big decisions
it's not the normal way to be but this
approach brought me success and being successful
allowed me to meet
extraordinarily successful people and  see how they
think
i have discovered that their journeys were
similar to mine you may not know it but
they all struggle and they all have
weaknesses that they get around working with
people who perceive risks and
opportunities that they alone would
overlook
over time i learned that naturally
the greatest strengths of
most people are also linked
to their main weaknesses and that
trying hard for big things is
sure to make you suffer
painful falls is just part of the
process these setbacks will test you
classify people some think hard
about what caused their setbacks
they learn lessons and keep moving
towards their goals others decide that this
game  ego is not for them and they leave the court
i have understood that the fact is not a
matter of achieving our goals
bill that as we reach each new and
higher level of success i am
rarely satisfied
the things we strive for are
just the cep  fighting for them forces us to
evolve and it is this fight towards
personal evolution with others that
is the reward I no longer wanted to go
through the jungle instead I was
looking for bigger and bigger challenges to
face them surrounded by
wonderful people and working together on a
shared journey
eventually the success of the mission and the
well-being of those who accompanied me
became more important than my own success
I also began to see beyond
myself and wanted others to succeed
when I no longer
understand that if I do not succeed I will be a
failure
this is what i
struggle with now we all struggle with different things at
different times
until we give up or die and
become part of the great kingdom  ate
of evolution
this is how all machines work
and they recycle over time
when a machine breaks down its
parts go back into the system to become
part of new machines that also
evolve over
time sometimes this makes us sad because we get so
attached  to our machines but
seeing it from a higher level the
functioning of the machine of
evolution is beautiful
now you must decide for yourself how you have to
evolve
forget where these principles come from it is
enough to judge if they are
useful to you and develop them according to
your needs as  With all
the life decisions you made with them, it
ultimately depends on you. The only
hope I have for you is that
you have the courage to fight well.
Thank you and goodbye.
[Music]